Kid Buu is not the strongest Buu let's
get into it I'll start with the manga
there it's pretty obvious that while Kid
Buu is no slouch he is a downgrade in
power from what came before not only
because it's just obvious at face value
I mean Goku outright says that they
don't stand a chance against superb and
then manages to put up a fight against
kidb but also because it's basically
outright explained he is just stated to
be the most chaotic or difficult form of
boo a boo with no inhibitions or just
pure chaos incarnate but this all gets a
little complicated once the anime comes
around because the anime states that kid
bu is the strongest of all the Boos
multiple times of course the problem
with this is that nothing else has
changed in the anime other than these
lines so they make no sense how could
Goku and Vegeta be no match for super
boo much less buot tanks or buhan but
easily go toe-to-toe with kidu who is
supposedly stronger than all of them